der tag nach dem corona gipfel heute
morgen wurde das geänderte
infektionsschutzgesetz im bundesrat
durchgewunken einschneidende maßnahmen
kommen auf uns in deutschland zu in
diesem winter und wir begrüßen bei uns
bild chefredakteur johannes brilo
johannes walter thomas johannes jens
spahn hat heute in einer pressekonferenz
noch mal gesagt es müsse dringend
gehandelt werden denn es ist zehn nach
zwölf nun würde man sagen wer um zehn
nach zwölf handelt der handel zu spät
mit welchem gefühl gehst du in diesem
corona winter mit einem sehr schlechten
gefühl thomas ich glaube die
bundesregierung hat ganz vieles
verschlafen und genau wie du es richtig
sagte es darf eigentlich erst gar nicht
zehn nach zwölf werden in der politik
die warnungen waren da auch viele
politikerinnen und politiker haben in
den letzten monaten immer wieder darauf
hingewiesen das wird so nicht reichen
das wird eine sehr ernste lage werden im
winter warum hat man dann nicht nur
nicht früher reagiert sondern auch ganz
offensichtlich nicht ausreichend
vorbereitet ich höre aus dem einen oder
anderen im zentrum das dort erneut leute
die sich impfen lassen wollten jetzt mit
den booster shots abgewiesen wurden weil
ganz bürokratisch zb die sechs monats
frist ab wann man bis vor kurzem noch
sich den booster geben lassen sollte
nicht ganz abgelaufen war sondern es
kamen eben leute die sind mit fünf
monaten ablauf und ein paar tagen schon
dort gewesen die wurden dann nicht
geimpft das zeigt eigentlich dass die
bundesregierung ihre hausaufgaben nicht
gemacht hat johannes angela merkel hat
im letzten jahr gesagt wir erinnern uns
alle noch es braucht noch eine
anstrengung gefühlt ist es jetzt wieder
anstrengend ist es noch viel
anstrengender jetzt was schief gelaufen
in ihrer corona politik ja dieses einmal
ist auf das du an spiels aus dem letzten
jahr das ist wirklich ein ganz klares
zeichen dafür wie viele falsche
versprechungen auch den bürgerinnen und
bürgern immer wieder gemacht wurden
damals war merkel den tränen nahe im
bundestag das fand ich auch sehr
empathisch sehr rührend sie sprach davon
wenn man jetzt nicht die kontakt
beschränkung wirklich hart durchziehen
würde würde es das letzte weihnachten
mit den großeltern wo möglich sein
so hat ein ganz düsteres bild gemalt
viele fanden es im nachhinein auch zu
düster ob es so gestimmt hat sei mal
dahingestellt jedenfalls versprach sie
jetzt kommt das impfen und dann wird
alles besser jetzt sind sehr viele
geimpft und zwar über 60 auch eine zahl
die aus regierungskreisen und auch von
bundesministern immer wieder genannt
wurden als dann wird es wirklich
substanziell besser aber es ist nicht
substanziell besser es ist insofern
natürlich besser als sehr viele leute
geschützt sind das impfen ist der
schlüssel zum erfolg gar keine frage
aber wieder stehen wir vor allem winter
in dem ernsthaften lockdown diskutiert
wird und vermutlich auch diskutiert
werden muss
16 jahre war angela merkel
bundeskanzlerin sie musste uns durch
einige krisen schiffen die große
flüchtlingskrise aber vor allem die
korona krise das war jetzt gestern
mutmaßlich ihre letzte bund länder
konferenz in drei wochen wird sie nicht
mehr kanzlerin sein welches corona erbe
hinterlässt sie uns sie lässt
und grundsätzlich erstmal mit einem
gespaltenen volk zurück einer spaltung
die sich jetzt durch kroner und während
corona noch mal extrem verstärkt hat die
bundesregierung hat es nicht hinbekommen
wie es andere länder hinbekommen haben
die leute auf eine fast entspannte
solidarische art vom impfen zu
überzeugen es blieb in deutschland immer
bürokratisches blieb in deutschland auch
immer höchst kompliziert eine impfung zu
bekommen viele leute waren davon nicht
überzeugt wurden auch nicht überzeugt
jetzt ist es wirklich ein gespaltenes
land das sich natürlich auch noch auf
ganz vielen anderen themengebieten zeigt
themengebiete zu den angela merkel auch
beigetragen hat stichwort migration
stichwort digitalisierung
energiepolitik also ein ganz schwieriges
erbe für die ampel die ja mit
allerhöchster wahrscheinlichkeit unsere
künftige regierung stellen wird